i remember when we did trigger nobody
last year you said to me
that
you thought something good
would come from it
i can't actually believe
well i can actually
now you can back then you didn't [ __ ]
believe me did you well
when you said that there was nowhere in
this world i could have envisaged
what kim
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people it doesn't get any more honest or
fascinating than the returning guests we
have for you today i can't tell you how
happy we are to have him back chris
mcglade the comedian
actor and all sorts of other great
things welcome back man welcome yeah
it's been great uh to be asked back well
it's a it's an absolute pleasure uh i'll
remind people you can like looking like
laurence louelle in boyne
you bang on about the working class but
you've come dressed very very middle
class today well you see the thing is
i've just been in uh this bowser up the
road from middle wall right and i've
only been to millwall once with the
borah many years ago and if you would
have said to me when i was in milwaukee
match before that parts of
this area of london would be it would
end up being gentrified right and i said
go on [ __ ] off right but i was in this
bowser there
and it's all your
main
like middle class super middle class
tabitha's and josh's with the half-mast
jeans and the [ __ ] trainers and all
that you know what i mean and i thought
myself wow
millwall's becoming the isle of dogs
you're going to become gentrified can
you believe that the world has changed
my friend but it has changed in good
ways as well one of the reasons we
wanted to have you back because i remind
people last time you were on the show
and we got such incredible feedback
people really loved what you had to say
it was because you'd had a show
cancelled from the soho theater
and you really were kind of your weekend
in terms of trying to get your voice out
there get your message out there get
your comedy out there
uh quite a lot it's changed things
right so like
i'm a spiritual blokmy right
and um and i work on art
and um
and i i honestly think right
like
like years and years ago
it's nothing this this actually happened
to me years and years ago when i was
uh
living in in a place called hindu well
near near whitby
i was at the absolute
well i thought that was the absolute
bottom i couldn't get a gig i was like
like like six seven months in between
gigs and all this
and i i wrote this this like in a clock
and generally like in a voice all the
time i just like follow it really and
call it intuition or whatever but this
thing said like you know these times
when you haven't got anything right
don't kick back embrace it
because when
you're break comes and it will come
right it will make it even more
unbelievable
and and that is the position that i
found myself in
uh
last year
you know i mean last year was
i've had some hard times maybe he's not
as hard as other people in their lives
you know
but last year for me was me scribbling
the bottom of my
like existence jeremiah
like i
i
uh i completely let myself go
go
after the first lockdown and you had a
little break and then we went into the
second lockdown and i really went to a
place
that i'll never go back to again hence
why i've gotta think i'm never gonna go
back yet again
i let myself go i was drinking three or
four bottles of whiskey a week
i'd grown this massive beard my hair was
like mosses i've been phenomenal i
couldn't get into a hairdresser nobody
could
but i lost my motivation
i lost everything you know and um and it
got to the point where
i woke up one night and i was quite
sober actually
and it was two in the morning and uh and
i put a belt around my neck
right
not to actually do it
right i just wanted to see what it felt
like
i mean in 2019 i tried to do it when my
wife and i parted company
and i actually tried it that time but
this time when i put the belt on my neck
last year
i
i didn't want to do i just want to i
wanted to see what it felt like
and i think that was scary because i it
was like i was
going down a tunnel
i was like slipping further and further
into i and i was like it was like slippy
on the inside i couldn't get out
and i spoke to this
ladder power and
who had actually done it
and he'd actually done it anybody who
god was good and he was found
and he said to me if you've done that
then you've got a massive problem
and i said why is that like and he said
because i did the exact same thing i
tried it well just tightened it and see
what it felt like at the same time of
night you know
and so i thought okay there's a problem
there
obviously the problem there
and i thought that was the lowest point
of my life
and the lowest point in my life actually
wasn't in the lowest point in my life
i have one daughter
and two stepsons
but my daughter is like my blood
and she's my world
and uh i went on to a house and her
partner's
grandma
who sadly passed away a week a week ago
i mean obviously i
knew her well
and she came in the kitchen she didn't
recognize me for it for a couple of
seconds i'm sure it's me like you know
and she said well i didn't even
recognize you chris you know
so we had a cup of tea and everything
and as i was leaving my daughter's house
about half an hour later i was close to
the front door and in the kitchen i
heard my daughter say
to a partner's grandma i'm never so
sorry about me dad
you know he's just having a few problems
well i absolutely i left the house and i
got into the car and i broke my [ __ ]
heart
i absolutely brought my art that my
daughter
had had to
make
an apology for me
i mean i always wanted to be like the
dad
that
you know i mean you can see it there's
two ways of saying that's my dad isn't
it
you can you can have somebody saying
that's my dad
right now oh that's my dad jermaine
and i always wanted the first i always
wanted to be that's my dad
and to think that my daughter was making
excuses for me
but it just brought my heart
i mean i can control
because i'm in a good place now i can
control the emotion where like last year
when we did this thing
i was in a really hard position and i
couldn't control the emotion
and i was in the car and i always
remember i was crying and this has
happened to me once before
when my daughter was about five i had no
money i had no gigs
i was absolutely at my wit's end
and i was in bed with my girlfriend at
the time and i was breaking my heart
like absolutely breaking my heart crying
and in the tiniest voice i just said
please god help me
and
and
in an instant
i stopped crying
and i just sat up and i said
everything's gonna be all right and the
following day
an agent phone and said i've got a
couple of gigs for you and off i went
again and it was that
kind of moment again last year when i
was in my car outside my daughter's
house
i was breaking my heart and i just said
just in a tiny voice please god help me
and i realized no
that was the absolute bottom
for me personally that was the bottom of
my life
because i had everything taken away from
me my wife had left me
dad had been murdered
i was in his house with only a chair and
a bed and everything right
nothing no money no gigs note
and about
two or three minutes later all of a
sudden i thought [ __ ] this
get yourself off to contemporary
hairdressers and whippy
for a cotton color
right
because i get the old burnt it's paul
mccartney brown at the moment like you
know
but i get like a bass fret we'll call it
bass five to call it and i phoned up the
airdressers and i said right book me in
for a haircut
and i go there for the crack as much as
anything else because i get hungry with
all the lashes
and that's
what started
the bounce back
i remember putting a post on facebook
about it
you know this has been you'll burn it
this would mean your work
i'm back kind of thing and strangely
enough
that's how it started it started with a
haircut and a shave
um they wouldn't shave me in in the in
the hairdressers because of the corvids
and stuff but i went at my daughter's
house and i shaved all my wishes she was
playing foot because i was there all
clogging the sink and everything you
know
and then the soho theater
they
canceled me out
and i did the live thing on facebook
uh
much to the annoyance of the promoter
and and his team
but i felt as though i had to say
something i didn't do it to solid
shitster or you know anything like that
and of course that's when comedy
unleashed came in
for me
and uh
so they said we'll put you on the
backyard
well
that sort of like
ushered in the next phase
because i've cleaned myself up
and the next phase was
was me
um
starting to rehearse forgiveness again
your show yeah because i'd and that was
the show that i was going to put on at
the soho theater they canceled me out
comedy unleashed said we'll do it at
backyard
so i thought right it's got to be ready
especially when
and this i couldn't believe this right
we sold out in two days 300 tickets boom
gone i'll make wow
you know what i mean i i was like the
biggest comedy night in london
on the i think was the third of october
or 12th i can't remember no 11th of
october
and uh
and so it had to be right
and so i started walking again because i
hadn't walked for a while
i'd been doing a lot of walking when i
walked to london and everything you know
against lockdown
and and i started walking again and
going talking to myself walking around
the streets of red car and stuff going
through the gig going through the gig so
that was up and then a couple of
little spots came in
they've got my confidence back you know
they did one stead comedy for
uh john fentman
good guy john yeah he's smashing lad i
got a lot of time for him and um and so
that that happened and then we actually
did the gig at uh
at uh
backyard and that well you were the lads
were there i mean
it was off the scale you know
and there's a lot of trigonometry fans
that have seen your interview with us
well
i i i for me i mean i remember when we
did trigger nobody last year you said to
me
that
you thought something good
would come from it
i can't actually believe
well i can actually
now you can back then you didn't [ __ ]
believe me did you well
[Laughter]
see this is the essence of faith isn't
it do you know the essence of belief as
a spiritual man i realize because my
faith and belief in a lot of things
um has been tested it's like a like an
elastic band like pull pull pull pull is
it going to snap
but
when you said that there was no way in
this world i could have envisaged
what came i
after we did backyard i did another
performance at the albany for my agent
michael
and that was great people who'd been a
backyard the night before came again
fantastic
uh
i went home and i thought right what am
i gonna do now
sick of living like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i was like living like a homeless person
in this house do you mind
i thought right now i got i i took the
money from
the comedy unleash gig
i thought right i want to
buy some stuff from my house because all
he had was a chair and a bed
right
wardrobe
and uh and it was minging i hadn't
cleaned it or anything absolutely
minging
so i started that process off and that
took a couple of months two and a half
months
and come
december
i
had my house
uh
back on blob it was like immaculate do
you remember carpets down people great
i'd put a post on facebook i'd put a
post on twitter
just say look i need to buy some things
cheap i've gotten the money from from
backyard
people saying here chris i have this
fridge freezer it's been in my garage
just need to freeze the light chris have
this microwave here chris
my mum died i've got a memory for
mattress in bed for your gran when your
grandkids come the the kindness was
unbelievable
didn't want anything for it you know i
like and that that just like blew me
away so my house
was
up and running my comedy was up and
running
i was like back in the land of the
living
i hear my grandchildren stay with me
with the mum halfway through december
that was just the [ __ ] best
we all had christmas hats on and
we had naughty elf and all this you know
that was unbelievable
my best mate mags came down the house
margaret calling or she cried when she
saw the elves she said i'm so proud of
you
and then [ __ ] me
the day before
christmas eve
i got a call
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
bridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anthem has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
the day before
christmas eve
i got a call from comedy unleashed
how are you doing i said i'm all right
like
have you got anything planned for
forgiveness
no
oh well uh we'd like to take you on a
tour
i'm like you're joking on you said no no
we maybe it's just a small tour six
nights
i said okay then
well lana's up with your agent michael
and we'll get it sorted
so i said okay
so the following day i thought they'd
leave it after christmas
christmas eve michael ford
comedy at least have been in touch they
want to put you on a two tour six nights
newcastle leeds manchester liverpool
birmingham and london
that sounds great that's fantastic you
know i mean
what a christmas present
but that wasn't it
because on christmas day
oh i never go on twitter but i went on
twitter on christmas day and somebody
had sent me a message
and this person said
uh
i like what you say
and i'm like do ya
and i said yeah we do yeah
and um
i'd like to make you a donation
so they said
um i'd like to uh make it are you gonna
pay pelican i said no well i have but i
don't use it
so
i gave him on christmas day my bank
details right
and i went for my christmas dinner at my
daughter's house and i was playing
football with my grandson in the front
garden i'm thinking you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you've given somebody right
complete stranger like your bank details
what's going on
so
i got back in touch and i said
look i don't know who you are and they
said oh we're going to put i want to put
this much money in your account and i'm
like hi okay then
oh yeah because it was you know quite a
hefty sum
got to after
bank holiday in monday nothing had gone
in the account i said look yeah
now i know
that social media is
full of [ __ ] really
right and i know people took the piss
right so they sent me this screenshot
right of the bank transfer
well i got up on a wednesday morning i
checked my account and it had gone in
saw a message back and i was at dunnell
buying a frying pan
[Laughter]
and i said you know how to party yeah
absolutely
finally got money get a frying pan get a
flying pan
and i said uh look i'm never sorry for
doubting you right
um
but
the money's gone in and
and i can't thank you enough
so this person said
well it's time for me to come forward
now so i'm like okay
and uh basically this person
is in the medical profession
in a foreign country
and they'd seen me
on trigonometry
and they said
i love your message of forgiveness
and uh and i want to put you on a tour
right well it wasn't going to be a sixth
night tour
they said i want to put you on a
30-night tour
of forgiveness
and i'm going to pay for everything
and i'm going to
make sure that you get
um an allowance
every night to pay for your travel and
everything else
and uh
and i have all the faith and belief in
you in the world
and i am sat with side to nelm right
he's freaking flying panning me and
right
and i'm thinking
michael ain't going to believe this
so i found michael and i told him right
long story short within
about
five days six days
like a five-figure sum
i've gone into my agent's account
and my account
to pay for this tour
and everything that we needed
and uh
[Music]
and for me like
that's just these things don't happen
but they do happen
and i realized
when it happened
that that little inner voice that i had
maybe about 2014 2015 when i was like
a gig once every six or seven months
when it said you know embrace these
times now when you haven't got anything
because when it comes
it's going to make it even more
unbelievable
well it [ __ ] was
and i mean we're going on a 30 night
tour
there's 30 dates
and it's going to be england scotland
island and wales
can't wait to do um
can't wait to do belfast because that's
where
my dad's side and the family were and of
course taking
the message of forgiveness to belfast
with about all the troubles
for me
it's just a massive thing jeremy
and uh
and i'm going on tour
it's just
just everything
that's what an incredible story
absolutely
and you see i don't have any
expectations of it you know i i
i don't have one expectation of that
tour because let's be
real
i'm a nobody right i haven't had any
television credits
i don't have
any great following
i don't have like fans or you know like
massive
i mean they have my facebook
friends and everything
five thousand people on one account and
i think five thousand people on the
comedy thing but i mean you know
i haven't got like a massive following i
mean there's there's people with
television profile struggling to sell
out tours and stuff
so
i have hopes but i have no expectations
of of the tour
but there again you see
it doesn't it's almost like it doesn't
matter
do you what i mean yeah
whether the whether each shore gets
one person in and obviously i would want
more than that but if it gets one person
in or the room sold out it's almost like
it doesn't matter because i've realized
when i wrote forgiveness i can see now
right
that the whole thing
was kind of like it's almost like meant
to be if you know what i mean
i mean when i first wrote forgiveness
i'd written like a two hour show and i
realized i'd written a two hour show
and my friends said to me andy and
magazine said well you know what you're
going to do because you only got like 55
minutes at edinburgh
and i just said well you know hopefully
i'll take it take it into my theater and
like do the full thing
and that's what's happening
jeremy so all the stuff that i'd written
that for me is very pertinent to the
story and everything else
make it a two-hour show with a break
it's now starting to happen and i just
feel as though whatever happens
with the tour
it's meant to [ __ ] happen
should you remain and i don't think it's
going to be the end of it
i think i think it's
i just think it's it's
it's going to get bigger and bigger you
know i i i
back just by virtue of the fact the way
things have gone you know yep yeah just
coming straight out the blue
you know
what are the chances of somebody in the
medical profession in a foreign country
watching your program thinking
i like this man and what he has to say
and yeah the world does need more
forgiveness
and you see the person who's backed me
financially for the tour
they said to me just two days ago they
don't have any
financial expectations
at all they're not bothered
you know i want them to have their money
back i want to make
it you know get enough people in to pay
this person back
but they have no expectations of that
they said
all they're bothered about is the
message of forgiveness
you know and i and i look at the way the
world is at the moment
and
and i think that's
that's what's needed most of all
jeremy to me you know what it shows it
shows the power of honesty chris
because when i i saw your show it was
one of the first previews you ever did
uh john fenterman's gig yeah once i said
comedy and constantin took me along and
said you've got to go to this you've got
to watch this this is brilliant and you
you weren't exactly going out and seeing
loads of shows at the time no because i
was gigging six nights a week
yeah i was busy and he went no no but
you've got to see it and it was the
third i think it was the third preview
that you did third or fourth certainly
no more than that
and what struck me was the power of your
words the honesty the integrity behind
it
and in our industry let's be honest we
don't really get a lot of that no well
i think the industry
i would never slag any comedian off ever
i [ __ ] would
is because it's too hard a job it is a
hard job it's too hard a job
and for me anybody whether they've been
growing 30 years 40 years five weeks
right
you have the boss to stand up in front
of an audience and try and make them
laugh
right
and you've got my respect
end of
you know lawrence olivier i remember
seeing him on on parkinson years and
years ago
and pattington said if you hadn't been
an actor
what would you have been he said i would
love to be in a stand-up comedian
germain because of all the entertainment
genres
stand-up comedy is the most difficult
because you go into a room
and you don't know what people
have done that day or what kind of lives
they've got or whatever
you know and yet you know to make people
who are in a low frame of mind
laugh
is a massive thing it's a very powerful
thing
and so i wouldn't i wouldn't sort of
like
decry or denounce any comedian do you
mean there's certain comedians i like
like to watch and there's other ones
granted my interest in comedy isn't the
same as
when there was people like my wives on
the go and stuff because
and tommy cooper they were like
comedy heroes of mine i could watch
eddie's ad all day long but not laugh
but love him gentlemen i said that i
said that to him
when when he came he took me uh for
supper went for super win in he's got
he's got parts she has in his club in
london and after me last night at the
soho theater i got invited along to see
his gig he'd been running all these
marathons and he'd done this show
in
the leicester square theatre
and we had the same promoter mick and
we sat down and ate and everything
and um
and i said you know yeah like i don't
laugh really at you
and he got that because she said well
you're a comedian yourself and you got
that you understood i wasn't being rude
but
i said like you know but i could watch
you all night
i could actually you know what i mean
but i feel as though there's a lot of
comedians these days the they don't
they don't use comedy perhaps as they
should be there's so many things
that we should be speaking out against
and
it seems that a lot of comedians are all
too
bothered about
just being safe in case it affects
the work the career or their ability to
get up and you see that's the thing
with me i mean the comedy circuit's done
me i mean basically i'm a working men's
club comedian
following the double and the bingo and
strippers and all this you know and stag
does and stuff like that you know
the glam stuff yeah absolutely
well i let me trade and stuff you know
but
but i've always sort of like pushed
myself as a comedian yes and i've always
got off my ass and i've i've gone on the
comedy circuit and i've always gone down
great on the comedy circle but it's
never been
really more than open mic spots
and you know like
ten minutes heroes five minutes i mean
it's
it's crackers really you know what i
mean it's um for me it's exploitation in
a way i mean i remember being at camden
comedy for avid and being a few years
back now when there was a young young
lad there young comedian he was trying
to get a
uh
a comedian's union going
and because he said it was exploitative
and and i agree
you know you're getting like two
comedians
like in the middle doing 10 minutes each
for now you've got like you've got like
a comedian this start doing it maybe
he's 80 quid 100 quid and you've got
your deadline
wherever he gets 200 quid or whatever it
is you know what i mean
and um
and so i think it's exploited and a lot
of comedians
would actually like to get in the store
and stuff the comedy store or whatever
they'd actually probably pay
if they could get a decent spot at the
comedy store you know
but they're not
comedy is i don't feel as though
comedies
like challenging as
it should but you know why that is i
mean look at your own story you were
just telling us what a life it what life
can be for somebody who wants to
talk about things who wants to push that
envelope
one gig every seven months yeah that's
why they're not doing it man yeah but i
mean
you know i agree with you well but you
see the thing is that this is another
thing i mean
i
i i reached my my end point
with the comedy circuit in 2019
i mean i was i've been in comedian now
for 34 years
i've been in like the i was in the main
comedic part in billy elliot in the west
end right
i played at the comedy store in
hollywood on the main stage with dane
cook and harlan williams and bobby lee
and all these guys right
uh
[Music]
i've done like loads of things
in comedy playing every kind of audience
you can think of not
not just
like that comedy circuit you know i
remember working with alfie brown one
time
got a lot of time for alfie i think he's
a great comedian jeremy but i worked
with him we did it i'd been working for
the black watch over in scotland
and i flew back and on the sunday him
and i went to exeter
to do a gig like you know
and i mean he was everything that i'm
i'm not in comedy really
but like he watched me and we got back
in because he was driving he got back in
the car
after the gig and i did a great gig
and uh he said i've got something to
[ __ ] say
before i set off i thought there we go
and he went
that was seriously [ __ ] brilliant
chris right you know i mean and you
shouldn't be in that position and i was
like wow you know what i mean because
he was with a
big agent and stuff like that you know
it was a massive
compliment for me
but this is what francis was trying to
say chris is we've had
however many hundred people on the show
now
people don't get that response that you
got
and that's what he was talking about
when he was talking about your honesty
and your authenticity which also comes
through an economy because we went to
see your show once you'd come on the
show and there was a load of
trigonometry fans there and whatever
and that's what people are responding to
because you're being honest yeah well i
mean that's that's just how how i am
yeah yeah
in the world that where very few people
are that way it stands out is that what
you were i was going to say but that's
not how most comedians are chris you
know it's that old david mamet line you
know you you love the fear to see i'm
sure you love mammoth words that come
from the heart go to the heart they hit
they hit hard whilst words that have no
meaning or a disingenuous
they don't hit because there's there's
no emotion behind them there's no truth
the thing the thing is when i when i
write something and i perform it right
then it has to make me laugh
first and foremost so i have to feel it
and if i don't feel it i can't that's
the thing with me for me to put my
company across properly i have to feel
it if i don't feel it
then i can't i can't put it across i
can't be like fake do i mean
probably my best
pal on the circuit of ever on the comedy
circuit was a guy called bobby knox all
in the 60s and 70s was tipped to be like
massive you know
yeah like he was sunderland's answer to
bobby thompson
and he always said to me the most
important thing in comedy
is to be honest
because an audience can spot a [ __ ]
fear
a mile off you know what i mean and
that's
basically what i've tried to do my whole
career you know some people that might
piss
some people off
but my
my my cutoff line i was saying was 2019.
because i'd done all the
i'd written to all and emailed all the
top agencies the off the curbs and the
avalons
and you get the same you know thanks but
no thanks and then you know you get back
you get back again no
no no it's okay we don't want it yeah
but i've done this now it doesn't
doesn't matter what you've done we're
not interested let you know
and i've done all the open spots and
then the open spots again
and i'm thinking in [ __ ] you know
like you're doing like an hour and 45
minute
spot improvised like comedy and you
don't they don't want to know
and it plays like a massive man game
yeah and you're trying to impress these
people all the time the different
promoters around the country they still
don't want to know that's fair enough
that's up to them that you know the the
vocal they wanna bug
and that but it makes you think well
what what what what am i doing wrong do
you mind i'm i'm storming my audiences
what am i doing wrong
so you carry on doing the five minute
open spots down in peterborough for [ __ ]
all you know you're doing like an um an
opening spot down in bristol i did one
one friday night drove all the way to
bristol for like uh 110 quid it cost me
95 in petrol unfolding [ __ ] drink but
you know what i mean i thought myself
well rather than me sitting on my ass in
our house get off your ass and do your
trade yeah and you never know what can
come from it no
and that's what that's what i basically
i would have been doing and then the
the absolute bottom came
in 2019 i'd written forgiveness i had
rehearsed forgiveness and i'd done
a couple of um previews of it and
this promoter from
down south in essex i think it was he
asked me to go and take part in this
comedy competition
at this really like low level
um
uh
uh
festival in in chelmsford i think it was
he lord it was [ __ ] awful
jeremiah and um
i know
there was no fee on it
just you know just the promise that if
you if you won this competition you'd
get 200 quid
and the way the way he was putting it
across to me was like we've all been
there man we've all been there yeah but
i mean i'd be like well you've been
doing it for 30 years 30 odd years yeah
and i was you know
and so i went there and the the
and i came nowhere and the the two lads
that it was there was a joint thing
and the the
the two lads were what it was one lad
uh
he was a comedian but he he'd actually
come to see me the year before in
edinburgh when i did northern monkey
and uh he he told me that i'd inspired
him to start comedy again right i knew
that blessing was it was he was autistic
and he'd only been doing comedy five
weeks
and i thought myself [ __ ] me uh
i can't beat somebody who's been going
five weeks
and i can't beat somebody who had
inspired to start comedy again
and i got in the train to go on the
following day
and i thought this madness has to
[ __ ] stop man
you know the circuit isn't humiliating
yeah
you're humiliating you i'm humiliating
myself
and it was strange because
i made that decision that's it i'm not
gonna you know i've i've i've got off my
ass and i've
proved how much this job means to me and
none of them want to know and i can't
get a gig on the comedy circuit and you
know i can't get a gig in the main clubs
like the
uh top secret or
the comedy store or whatever you know
what i mean and uh and i just thought
not enough
just enough
jeremiah
and strangely strangely enough as i was
on that train going home
i
i just looked at that i got this this
thing on facebook a notification and it
was the right to hit
and and
it had been on like nine thousand views
for about a year your poem yeah
nine thousand views for a year and then
all of a sudden i looked he's gonna be
fifteen thousand in about one hour and
by the time i got off the train at redka
it was like 25 000 right
and then it was off
and for like two weeks or whatever three
weeks before edinburgh it had like
nearly a million views
because it went viral twice yeah that
was the first time went viral and i
thought myself no and that's us and it
was weird
once again it's based in the spiritual
but like once
i made the decision that that that was
it i wasn't
gonna humiliate myself by
doing these five and seven and ten
minute spots for nothing or 15 minutes
at the start for 50 quid like you know
150 mile away once i made that decision
not to do that all of a sudden the right
to hit
just started to build up a dynamic of
its own and then enough we went to
edinburgh and then of course after
when i took forgiveness to edinburgh
that yeah and it was just critically
acclaimed across the board and then and
then you see it
and now i feel as though
like i'm not bothered whether whether i
do the comedy circuit or not now
jeremy it's nothing it's never given me
anything
you know some people have
[Music]
have been downright
awful
you know
uh but i
and said bad things but uh
i'm not bothered about that because i
i don't i try not to concentrate on the
people
who knock although as comedians you'll
know yourself you do don't you hmm do
you remain
you always concentrate on
you could have like a room full of
people loving you and then one or two
people not laughing and you'll
concentrate on those two rather than
all the rest but i try not to
concentrate on on the negatives and
and just
concentrate on the positives and
now i feel as though well you know
i've got a
tour
but it's even more than that you see
because like last august
i got a phone call off my agent michael
he'd come back into the
the frame
and uh
he said i'll put you in for this
movie
for the lead role have
you i can't say at this moment in time
right
over the director is right
he's one of the most iconic british
directors
ever
i'm putting him for the lead role
so we got the feedback oh yeah you know
so-and-so so and so knows what he can do
blah blah blah
we're not really bothered all of a
sudden it just changed
matt mate he's a a psychic
tony caller calling was armed robber
right from middlesbrough
a psychic taxi driver
[ __ ] unbelievable right
and this is no no i don't like you but
you laugh right he's as funny as [ __ ]
anywhere right proper rough assed smoggy
bought a taxi driver armed robber got
put away for armed robbery right
and he started doing these things and
when i was in edinburgh he was saying
you're gonna have a hollywood film
director and he'd contact you and he and
i did
so he was telling me uh you doesn't
matter
when i got this this michael told me i
was up for this movie
tony was saying uh
it doesn't matter that they're gonna
want you
right they're gonna this other irish
fellow was called eddie he was he was
the same they're gonna want you
long story short right
just before
i got the phone call
from comedy unleashed
i went off for the last casting and i've
got a part in this [ __ ] movie
this major british movie
so i've got like i tidied myself up i'd
rehearsed my act and started getting
small spots and stuff be just leading up
to
backyard comedy did backyard comedy
got a standard innovation for
about a minute and a half
got on the ocean yeah i got [ __ ]
tired of standing there i'll tell you
that's what you get with talents
[Laughter]
got all my house sorted
landed a part in a [ __ ] major british
movie that we start filming
this month
and now i'm on a 30-day tour and it's
just [ __ ]
unbelievable and i think myself well
i'm not saying i'm bigger than the
comedy circuit but do i need that [ __ ]
do i need the five do i need to try and
prove myself
you know on five and ten minute open
spots trying to get please give me a gig
please give me a gig i'll suck your dick
for a gig please
you never did that to me no no no no no
no no well that's why i don't know the
comedy promotion
i don't want to rush a new killer
do you know and i just think myself
you know
in all the years leading up to this
they gave me nothing
chris you don't even need to think about
it anymore man well but i do you see
because i'm i'm
this is your shot yeah this is your shot
and you just gotta [ __ ] take it it is
my shot and it is my shot i mean i mean
this is another and you know honestly
right i'm not kidding you right you
won't believe this right
eric clapton [ __ ] emailed me
i got like [ __ ] me
oh do you know what when i heard about
that because he watched his trigonometry
i was obviously delighted with it for
you i was like what the [ __ ] hasn't he
emailed me no he i don't think he
watches his trigger all right thanks
mate
just watch as chris mcglade there's no
this there's a there's a there's a guy
believable
there's a no gratitude these days
there's an acquaintance right i have
and he liked my stuff
so he's on uh
oh what's that what's that um or the
social network forum
take talk no not tick tock instagram no
no it's not parlor telegram telegram
yeah he's big on telegram he has a
massive following he's a free speech
advocate knowledge you know
and i sent him i'd seen clapton do this
interview
right
and he was telling people how the the
jab the kovid jab had affected his hands
and he got really emotional and he
mentioned this chap
so i thought well okay now i'll because
this chap is big on telegram and he's
you know an advocate he likes free suit
he came in backyard he's on the night
you you and anton did
so
i sent him some of my stuff and he loved
it
and like clapton liked it as well you
see
so i said would you ask eric if you
wanted to come the gig will
he messaged me back and he said alex
said he'd be absolutely honored to come
to your gig how many [ __ ] helicopters
you don't have to come to my key i'm
like you know
slow and you know
likes my stuff
and it's like
and on the night of the gig on the day
the gig
clapton messaged me emailed me and said
uh because of corvid and everything
he didn't want to take the risk of
coming to a
packed comedy thing
fair enough but he said we'll definitely
meet further on down the road which is
one of his songs
and i'm thinking like all this doesn't
happen to me
and so it's like
like my dad died in i finished in billy
elliot in
2000
my dad
had been murdered in 2000
and 11.
he'd be on the uh and i'd went and i'd
finish his political campaign in red car
and everything
and uh i'd come on billy elliot and all
that and there was nothing
and that's when i i'd spent all those
years 12 years begging top agents and
all these people please like come and
see me you know listen
i came close to off the curb offering me
a spot somewhere in essex
and then they pulled it and put this
irish chap in instead
um
and i'd done all that for the best part
of 12 years right
and then
after all these things happened
last year
i i don't feel as i have to i have to
sort of like humble myself or or back
anymore
i mean like i said
i don't know if the two is going to
do anything i mean you you've got like
300 000 people and like subscribing to
your channel if if 7 000 of those people
like
decided they like what they see and and
they want to buy tickets that's great
that's job done this interview that's
great you know what i mean it's like
every time you see a celebrity on a
telly on jonathan russell wherever
they're always [ __ ] selling something
and i suppose that's what i'm doing
today i'm trying to sell the show but i
want people to know
that no matter how bad you think things
are
if you keep
that belief
it might be in god it might be in spirit
it might be just in you
right it might just be in yourself
but if you keep that faith and belief in
yourself and [ __ ] me i'll tell you what
it was man was like this like stretched
to the limit
and i almost lost it
but i didn't lose it quite and if you
just keep it
then you never know what's right and and
i am living proof of that you know what
i mean and so that's why i've
i've come i mean i love you two of the
bits but that's why i've come on to this
thing again because i want
i'm i've built up this like social media
following now and people say oh yeah i'm
not inspired me through my darkest days
and all of this you know through
lockdown you're making those live videos
and it made sense to me and you know you
you didn't mind laying yourself bare and
showing his warts and all like you see
that comes down to being honest i
suppose
and people have gained comfort from that
and that that makes me feel very proud
you know what i mean so
if i can inspire people
you know to carry on going through my
story
you know and i have you know i've
scraped the bottom of the barrel and
stuff
but if i if i can inspire people to
carry on through my story then
then that that's all fair and well you
know and it's not about the comedy
circuit like beating me or me beating
the comedy circuit it's just you know
chris
francis will tell you a story about a
mutual friend of ours a comedian who
summed up the comedy circuit perfectly
do you remember
javier
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna i'll talk
about that do you know you know what
your story reminds me of i remember
reading stephen fry's autobiography have
you seen it no have you read it he talks
about star trek he's a huge star trek
fan and he relays a story from star trek
where spock and
captain kirk were looking out over the
galaxy and kirk looked at spock and he
said you know some you know something
spock there is somebody at this point in
the galaxy saying the three most
beautiful words in the world
please help me yeah
and that's it the moment where you reach
out and you go things have got to change
i can't carry on like this i can't do
this any longer i want to change
things change
honestly and that's
like i resonate with that massively
because i mean like i said that's
happened to me twice in my life i mean i
had a massive spiritual experience in
gran canaria
i'm not going to go into it now because
i'd be here for five days talking about
it the ramifications of it
like
i've left its mark on my life
like massively
people can
people can scoff
about spirit all things spiritual
and i get that
gentleman
i get that most people go without
you know i can touch this and it's the
lower and i can drink this tea and it's
nice and you know i can see you and i
can taste this
but like when
something happens that you can't see
touch feel hear smell or whatever right
but you know it's happened
uh
the only way i can describe it to you
it's like
it's like
your clock's ticking like this
and all of a sudden it stops
and then it starts
ticking like that
and everything but everything
is different
and that's that's what happened to me
and and i have got this
spirituality
and i have been
in that position twice in my life where
i
have asked something that i can't see
feel here or whatever
just
help me
yeah
and and
on both occasions
it's come from trump's
it's come up trump
and i can i'm not going to turn my back
on it
and i'm not going to deny it
it's very personal to me
it's based in
a lot of things
it's based in the love of my family my
grandchildren
i look at it now you know
and my grandchildren's great grandma i
like to say she passed away last week
and my grandchildren
uh
were upset about me
and they saw like once once a week or
whatever
and they see me nearly every day
and last week i thought to myself you
bastard
if you either killed yourself
how upset would the grandkids have been
and i thought to myself yesterday no i
want to live
i want to [ __ ] live
i don't want to die no more
and i don't want to go on shaving
anymore and i don't want to go scruffy
anymore
and i don't want to like you know
let myself go and collect things anymore
i want to live
because you've got things to do man this
is what i was going to say to you about
the circuit it's like a friend of ours
said to us this is why it matters
because there's a lot of people watching
this work in the comedy world but it's
not just the comedy world it applies
everywhere in life
so the circuit you've seen batman
it's like that pit
that no one's ever climbed out of
bait was the one and he said you guys
are one of the few people that ever get
to climb out of it that's all the comedy
circuit is now it's not true that it
didn't give you anything it gave you the
skill
you you had the chance to practice to
get better comedy circuit didn't give me
the
they're doing the comments because you
see this there's two there's two
there's two circuits isn't there yes
there's the circuit
i learned my trade
in stag shores
working men's clubs strippers
some of the things i've [ __ ] seen and
done on the circuit i remember working
in this
uh place the maid marion center in
nottingham right
or the robin hudson it was the made
marion suite
i worked with two strippers
on a wednesday night
it was [ __ ] awful
they left all the sex toys on the
[ __ ] floor
and it was like a scene from horror film
like this black dildo was [ __ ] like a
finger was crawling across the stage
like that you know
i remember doing it i remember doing a
stag stug doe in uh doncaster on a
sunday night
and i'm not lying here
at the end of this thing all the let's
have a whip around to get one of their
lives up right
and the strippers make a bit of an ass
of him like you know what i mean
and uh they got this gadget up started
stripping him off you know they're all
doing dancing around you know and
technician
all the lads are going crazy
one stripper got this leg like that and
this got that thing like that and then
like like that you know
pulling his shirt and the shirt and
stuff off to him his shoes and socks off
the first stripper grabbed all this
block show pulled it and the [ __ ] leg
came with it right he had a prosthetic
leg
so she stood
nice
with this gadget's leg with a [ __ ]
shoe on it and a sock right
well we were up there all room was
killing themselves laughing right
and it and that's where i learnt my
trade
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy dns is a company for you easy dns
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies
he knows about that so will you in a
second easy dns have rock-solid network
infrastructure and fantastic customer
support they're in your corner no matter
what the world throws at you unless it's
your ex-girlfriend in which case you're
on your own you know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is go to easydns.com forward slash
triggered that's easydns.com
forward slash triggered use our promo
code which is also triggered and get 50
off the initial purchase sign up for the
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
there was a video company came in for me
years and years ago i'd only been a
comedian about five years
and i made this uh
this video called true blue
and it was absolutely i mean i was awful
you know i wasn't ready for it at all
you know i mean
you know like when you see these
these football pundits and they're
talking about you know
should this club go up from the
championship in the premier league and
all the rest of it late
and you think well no you want to you
want to go in the premier league you
know well that's when i was like i was
well i wasn't even like championship you
know what i mean i was like maybe third
or fourth division
and i support this video company were
trying to put me in the top flight
and when i look at it i was nowhere near
ready in it
and it and it i mean
you've got to understand on that stag
circuit
the one as racist as you can possibly be
the one who's sexist is misogynistic and
sick the [ __ ] lot germain because
it's hard whether the whether the
audience is black or white that's that's
that's the nature of a stag comedian
jonah maine and that's what it was and
it was [ __ ] awful and they wanted the
wanted to do
this video in a theater in london and
they wanted to add it was alien to me
that would be quite a [ __ ]
they wanted they wanted to bust an
audience in right they wanted to bust an
audience in let's get some northerners
in yeah
and i had this i had this like mad well
i still got it because i love
tee's side
i love
the [ __ ] butter
and redka where i live i just love them
do you mean it's my home
well i said no i want to do it at the
doorman's club in middlesbrough
dolmen's club
um
oh what do you call it
bob uh
monk house and and other people there
that's what i'm gonna
so we did it there
and all it was like two coaches from
redkick came over to middlesbrough they
went in this club
the people from middlesbrough took an
exception with two two coaches already
that was the first time it was a
full-scale riot
and it was the first time that cs gas
had been used in t-side at my [ __ ]
video
and we got the cobble it up and we did
it again because my agent the time was
from south wales and we called it we did
it again this place
down in um
in south wales and it was just awful the
video was [ __ ] awful
i'm not proud of it at all
but i wasn't ready for it but that's my
background yes
then you've got the comedy circuit
you're what you what you would call the
comedy circle yes do you mean i don't
know what you mean like five comedians
or four comedians in an emcee and this
not near there no you know people echo
but if they do then you know echo too
much you get chucked out and all the
rest of it i mean
it's a complete different beast yeah
where i'm from i mean when i went to the
gig with alfie all those years ago i
don't know exeter
he had this like television
theme idea
about me and him like swapping so like
i'd go on that circuit that he did in
london in the south east or whatever and
he'd do like the clubs in the northeast
i thought was a great idea i mean i
would love to see him i i've seen
comedians on that comedy
circuit the london like london s kind of
comedy circuit
because they're putting
more and more of these comedy nights on
in working men's clubs now in the north
and i've seen some of these like circuit
comedians according to working men's
club and you can see the color like
drain out of them
you know because
they're really uncompromising
like you know like like places to work
yeah look my point is you've done all
that yeah yeah you've done all that
you've done all that and now you've got
your shot
and you've got a 30-day tour and you've
got a part in a movie and i couldn't be
happier for you
well uh listen
as i said to before when we did
trigonometry last year
at that time i had the show in front of
me
and
and that was it i didn't we didn't have
any more plans to do forgiveness
anywhere else
right
and that was that
and then we did it and now i've got the
opportunity now all i know is i've got a
part in a major british movie
with an iconic british director
and i'm on a 30-day tour
and i've got some other little bits and
pieces coming in on that after dinner
speaking circuit
so i've got money coming in job done
thank the lord to remain yeah you know
i've got a flier that would say the best
of times i do like to eat do you
mean beyond that
i don't know
i don't know i don't know if if the part
in the movie is going to lead to
anything i don't know if the 30 day 2 is
going to lead to anything
but
as i say because it came out of the blue
i just feel as though
all of this
if i was to
talk from a spiritual point of view
i feel all of this
is meant to be
and i and i honestly feel as though
it's not the end this person who this
medical person who from abroad who's
you know
uh who's come in and give me this uh
opportunity financially
uh i think they want me to to
to take it to america they want to take
they want me to take it to uh
australia and new zealand
you know and i mean
i'll do those things do you mind
of course i'll do those things
but that's in the future
you know i just want to get back to
performing regularly
to write in because because when i'm not
doing anything i can't see the point in
writing you know yeah yep um
it's like i've been a being a ship in
the doldrums you've got no wind in
yourselves you need one but once you get
the wind in yourselves and you're off
then then you're more creative aren't
you so i just want to i just want to
like
do these things
get my creativity back and
and let's take it from there
and i i hope
this was the thing
uh middlesbrough had a football striker
called bernie slurpin and he came to see
the show
i've only had five gigs this year
and one of them i did a performance of
of forgiveness in my hometown of redcard
and raised money for
uh
these two homeless charities
bernie slaven came and he said to me
after the show have you seen ricky
gervais his afterlife
i said no i haven't i don't watch telly
you know never watched telly
and he said well i watched your show
and he said uh and it was very similar
to that you know well i i've never seen
afterlife i don't know where you know
what it is
and then this other chap came over and
he went oh you chris i said well even
you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ] t-shirts
ricky javier he said have you seen
[ __ ] afterlife i said no i ever know
he said that's what it's like he said
it's [ __ ] wonderful right
and that meant a lot to me because i
mean
i have a lot of i don't think ricky
gervais is a better comedian than me
he's got more profile obviously
he's outspoken and i love that i love
the fact that he champions common sense
that he won't he won't bow down to the
the walk brigade the pig say brigade but
then again he's big enough you know
not not to
worry or bother about that you know what
i mean but i would love like
somebody like that to come and see the
show
or i was in this article in the
telegraph
on christmas just before christmas last
year
and
and i was like sandwiched in between
johnny depp
ellen degeneres john cleese and jk
rowling these are all people who've been
censored right in 2021
and i thought he said wouldn't it be
great if john cleese uh or jk rowling
thought i would know this person i'll go
on i'll go and go and see this show
because all it takes
what i'm saying you is all it would take
is for one of these people
to see it and think hang on i can do
this with it or i can do that with it
you know i maybe take it to another
level
you just you just never know dear
and so
that's why that's that's something i'm
hoping but i have no expectations for it
because i just think the way it's all
happened
it'll just be what it'll be and i'm
happy for it to be what it'll be chris
this is all incredible
but i think you're discounting
the power of that decision you made
where you said
no more
that's where it all comes from
to me
and that's the really powerful thing
about this story is someone
who was at the bottom who felt they had
no way out
realized that they were doing it to
themselves
and making a choice that it wasn't going
to be like that anymore
so if you keep committing to that choice
i get that i get that completely right
but no
no amount of
shaving and getting your hair cut and
colored right is going to make a doctor
from a foreign country give you a five
now that's trigonometry material that's
cryptic about this person by the way
because they've asked not to be
identified look you're in a great place
it's absolutely [ __ ] brilliant to see
i'm so proud of you i'm so happy for you
you're going to smash the tour everybody
go and make sure you buy a ticket we'll
put the link in the description
uh chris chris mcglade chris mcglade
the tickets are at chris i don't even
know the clue
this is our professional league well
listen i'm a fiftieth she's a great
comedian tech wise not so much yeah it's
uh it's
michael said because he's he's drummed
it into me there right
michael said the tickets are at
chrismangladecomedy.com
perfect and if you want it right sure
and if you want to click and if they're
not we'll put the correct link in the
description and if you want to click and
subscribe i'm back on facebook two
accounts and i'm on twitter but i don't
do instagram
perfect chris
uh we've always got one question at the
end we'll ask you a couple of questions
from our supporters
from our supporters for our supporters
but before we do what is the one thing
we're not talking about that we really
should be
once again class
you know
because you see i look at it this way
i am a very working class comedian and a
working-class man
and i and i don't
i don't think that working-class
comedians of that working-class style
right get uh
a fair
rub of the green when we done
backyard
last year
the guys at comedy unleashed
uh
said we want to put like a northern
working men's club night on
at backyard can you sort us like five
four or five comedians in an emcee and i
said yeah great and i said to some of
the lads on the circuit you know do you
want to be a part of this
let's see if we can change things
because it seems to me that the only
kind of comedy that these people who
dominate and control comedy
want to put on is
is their version of comedy and there's
millions of people out there who don't
subscribe to that point of view or that
taste in comedy do you mind
and oh for me it comes down to
discrimination of of that working class
style
of comedy so that's and pete like i said
before the last and i i went into the
fine ends of a fart about com about
class last time but
like nobody likes to talk about class do
they get embarrassed about it they feel
uncomfortable about it
you know one of the things that i was
really proud of with with
forgiveness went into the soho thing
it it it
went across everything it caught across
class divide race divide religion
everything gentleman until it was
cancelled
for even so i mean when we when we went
to this well that's the point you're
making that's the only reason i made
that quick is that yes it was until it
came across the taste makers of that
world
who because of those reasons
i've got to say this though
because the soho theater cancelled me
out because they said oh it's
anti-semitic you know the sort of
the the the poem the right to hear
i was contacted
by these two chaps and we become friends
and uh one of them
he founded the campaign against
anti-semitism
and uh and then he founded this movement
called the israel advocacy movement
and the other chap alexander
he's like like he's i don't know if he's
second in command i don't know if that's
the right term but the work handy glove
kind of thing you know
fear hound
like these these guys are like proper
well israeli advocates and the zionists
and jewish obviously you know
and just leading up to me doing the
uh
backyard
they'd seen the stuff about you know
this anti-semitic so they've done all
the things and they've gone through all
the tweets and blah blah blah you know
and they'd seen the stuff i'd put about
the rothschilds and banking and all this
you know
so they wanted to do this interview with
me right
and i will get emotional over this one
they wanted to do this interview with me
and i should write okay then i'll do the
interview right and then we're having
trouble the logistics of either the me
going on a london and then coming up to
red car
so i i said right i'll tell you what
we'll do
come and see the show
come and see the short backyard when
forgiveness goes in and then we'll do an
interview right
so they came along to the shore
and we're like 300 other people that
stood and applauded at the end
wonderful
after the show
the top guy joseph
he said to me
that was absolutely amazing he said
you've actually changed the way
i look at things
and i said in what way
and he said well
you made me realize
that people can say anti-semitic things
right but not be anti-semitic
they can see a amount of ignorance they
can see him out of a lack of education i
said well i'm glad you appreciate that
i said you know i'm a very intelligent
man
probably not the most educated people i
left school when i was 16 years old went
straight into a steel mill
jermaine
my professors and my lecturers
were people like ernie buchton and colin
alley and teddy tackett you know hating
stock diggers
rough ass steel menu remain
i said so but i've tried to educate
myself over the course of my life
and i've had questions and all this you
know and i've tried to answer the
questions in my own mind and
and he explained that to him and he said
well that's what i mean
but then the other guy with him
alexander
he said to me when i was sat there
and i thought to myself
but there's another aspect to this as
well
and i said what's that and he went
shouldn't we forgive the anti-sea mates
and that was like [ __ ] hell
like these people
are like committed
to the cause of
israel they've bashed
and attacked anybody who they think
is anti-semitic
and yet i'd kind of like
cut through that
and made them
see things in a different way and we've
become friends now alexander
offered me to come down to london
and have dinner with him and his family
for the sabbath
uh
they're going to get me what they call a
yid lid i want an orange one no because
orange in my favorite color
and they've endorsed my show
on on twitter
telling everybody to come and see the
show
now
the show
has cut as like cut through a lot of
things
and it's encouraged people to forgive
and it's encouraged people to forgive
themselves
and it's kind of like you know
built bridges again
but now it's like changing things
on like a massive political level as
well
you know these guys realize i'm not
anti-semitic
they realize that you know i'm growing
evolving changing i said to him you know
i'm still growing and evolving and
changing on the day i die
i'm still learning stuff on my last
breath i hope i've learned something
jeremy
yep
and so they they realize or what you
know i might have said stuff that's
anti-semitic on on twitter but then
again we will encourage our thoughts and
feelings
on social media conversations that you'd
have over one that might have over the
back fence or when you're washing the
car or you're nearby
or in the shop the queue you were you're
encouraged to have all those throwaway
conversations on on on social media now
where they're all stored and people can
think oh well you know he said this in
2009 you know this
but like all you're doing is like
using like social media as a sound board
for the things that you're thinking at
that particular time and these two guys
saw that germain and they realized there
was no managing scene so when i when
alex put that tweet on twitter
i sent it to the director of the theater
at the saw horror theater jeremiah not
to be clever or to piss up his back
or anything like that jeremiah but to
say look
and i said to him look if we can work
together in future get it on because
these are two guys
are massive in the jewish community
they're massive in that thing they know
that it's you know that it's not
anti-semitic they've seen the show
you know don't don't let
that progressive canceled culture
stopped because you see and this is the
crux of it all
that canceled culture
and that political correctness is
dividing people and ultimately
conquering them
has to [ __ ] stop
right because otherwise we're going to
be each of the thoughts all the time
and if and if my sure can go somewhere
to dismantling that canceled culture
and to be and to make people like joseph
and alexander
look at things in a different way do you
mean
then i think that's a [ __ ]
even more than making people forgive
that's a massive thing you know a
massive massive thing all power to you
chris
god bless you man thanks for coming back
on thank you for watching and listening
we'll see you very soon i mean it
probably won't be quite like this but it
will be another episode uh or or so they
all go out at 7 p.m uk time and for
those of you who do like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
honestly right i set up that because i
was desperate for finances in 2020 and
then i thought myself what the [ __ ] are
you doing
you